that is quite the fun group and they are
going to the postseason we found that
out this week the question is what will
the final record be mr mckenzie will be
our northeast ohio four dealers indian
starting pitcher today mackenzie five
and seven on the year
on the ground up the middle rosario nice
pick tim got in there tim is safe head
first
and the sox have two on with one out in
this first inning we'll bat with two men
on
rondolin a breaking ball slices it to
center field tim's around third throw
coming to the plate is not in time and
the sox who were shut out yesterday on
three hits have two first inning hits
and a run with one out
there's a weak ground ball too short
rosario goes to first the inning is over
the white sox get the first run the
indians are coming to back lucas giolito
looking for his 11th win of the year at
zra 370.
he like so many other of his
starting buddies they strike out a lot
of people 192 167 to two thirds believe
me he wants eight today
high pop look at he's battling the sun
billy hamilton can't find it and it's
gonna drop and headlong into second base
with a lead off double his mile straw
hamilton was never anywhere in the
neighborhood of that pop-up so obviously
rick he never saw it he's got it his
glove never went up to shade the eyes he
didn't let anybody know
that he couldn't see it bobby bradley
on a change-up slugged into left field
but playable eloy jimenez makes the
catch so the double does no harm and the
sox carry the lead into the second
inning now andrew vaughn another
struggling hitter in this white sox
lineup
and just struck him out on three pitches
bonds struggles continue he's really
tardy on the first fastball and you know
what they pounded it three straight
times and got the strikeout three
pitches all fastballs see you later
upstairs
back-to-back strikeouts for mckenzie two
down
well fastball has played well with the
last two hitters mckenzie's striking
them both out
so he has three now first time through
the hitters are batting 249 off the
chilido fastball
not much doing against the change up and
ramirez will swing at a lot of pitches
up and out of the zone
like that oh i'm sorry did i
i may have misheard you no i mean you
know you you see a tendency and then you
just go back to it and
lucas with his first strikeout
yeah that one
but up and out of the zone that's his up
and is out of the zone as you're gonna
see
on the corner strike three it was a
slider two gone
i think you pitched so i believe you
inherently this into right field
and vaughan makes catch to retire to
side garcia abreu and grand all coming
up in the third inning
the old one pitch ground ball into lap
that's a base hit
leori makes a turn around first he's
going to try for two loses his helmet
but he's got a double
3-0
nope ball four base is loaded after the
double eight of nine have been out of
the strike zone so this
is an early big moment in this game and
a long day behind beaver the day before
eloy rips this to left and down on a hop
in front of ramirez
here comes one here comes the second one
of ray you scores
after garcia and it's three nothing
socks here in the third
lloyd drives in a pair
it's a three to nothing ball game and
jose does a great job
he just runs right through
[Applause]
sheets to left field it's grondaal at
third ramirez comes in to make the catch
and yazmati will not tag demarlo hale
figuring he's already expended a lot of
energy
in this inning
and so the cleveland clinic call to the
bullpen
has been made
nick wittran coming on with the bases
loaded one out
bouncing ball bradley comes home with a
throw they get the force there for out
number two
yeah you're not because you don't get
two just get your first one give roberto
he's got the mask on just give him one
right at the shoulder
here it comes got him
oh he took a fastball right down
carnegie
white sox get a pair
but they leave them loaded quick
let's hope that lucas had a couple of
extra pitches because that was a very
long top of the third inning
three two
he did strike three one gone
third strikeout for giolito bobby
bradley three nothing socks bottom fork
pitch
check swing he went
that's strike three 4k is for giolito
bradley's out
chang swings and misses a fastball he's
out on strikes that's five
for g alito he's three away from 200 on
the year giolito three-nothing white sox
struck him out in the zone this time six
strikeouts
no walks that is a slider that you throw
when you want to throw a strike a new
pitcher in the ball game justin garza on
for the 20th time
the old one devaughn is
lined into center that's a base hit
he's one for three here's leori garcia
batting left-handed again the clouds
have taken over no sun at the moment
bounced towards center field in for a
hit
fawn will score
and leori garcia with an rbi single here
with two outs
this one just sneaks up the middle
a chance for miller but he can't get it
and there
is an insurance run which you love to
have
lucas giolito just made big pitch after
big pitch whether it was the slider the
change up or some high fast balls well
placed
he just was able to get the job done
so he should feel pretty happy about
this one he will leave the ball game
turn it over to michael kopak gave up
just the five hits in six innings and
walked only one all in all a job well
done
there's a smash
and that's gonna go to the center field
wall
and roberto perez is in the second base
with a leadoff double
going the other way it gets through
roberto will stop at third miles strong
right-hander against right hand payoff
pitch
line drive right field base hit
perez scores mercado stops at third
they're on the board three straight hits
to open the bottom of the seventh inning
as miles straw has his third hit of the
afternoon
payoff coming
on the ground
tim
laorie
oh boy safe to call at first base i
thought real time for sure he got him
we'll check
the socks i'd have to take another look
at it i i think clearly got him it's in
the glove now before the foot comes down
on the bag yes sir out done inning over
marlo hale will bring his infield in
they're down three and it's late pitch
with anderson on the move
throw down to second base now tim's
caught in a rundown billy hamilton's off
third tim's still in a rundown
hamilton's off third throw goes into
third now to talk to the play philly's
safe and the sox have rambunctiously on
the bases picked up run number five and
now harold ramirez to the plate one for
three today
there's a fastball hit well deep right
field on the run is vaughn he's out of
room it's out of here
the seventh home run of the year
for a big hero he didn't miss it no he
didn't he left that ball upstairs
and this ball carries curves it gets
right on top and just bounces over
didn't look like this was gonna be a
save opportunities
it has turned into one looking for his
36 save
on for the 66th time
[Applause]
to third moncada
has out number three in the sox win
in cleveland to finish off the season
series
and get right on back to 20 over 500.